Okay, so now you have a list of friends.
But not the ability to share
lists with those friends.
I'm going to split up the actual
sharing code into two parts.
The first thing we'll do is to simply
keep track of who is shared on
what list.
The second part, is making sure
that when a user is shared,
they get a copy of the list
in their own user lists.
And then on top of that,
whenever a list anywhere is updated,
that all of the copies of that
list are simultaneously updated.
Let's start by focusing
on this first part.
Okay, so
here we are back at the sharing flow.
And we're going to focus on the share
list activity specifically,
because we already dealt
with how to add friends.
When I press the great plus button here,
there needs to be a change in both
the UI of the share list activity and
the data in the database.
So let's talk about what
the change will look like.
Well for
the UI that change is pretty easy.
I'll see green check next to
the name of the person that I just
shared the list with.
In the database,
you're going to be changing around
what is in the shared with a list.
We can see the change here.
Since I added Lyla,
in shared with under the same push
ID as the list I'm interested in.
So right here.
We have the user data for
the user that I just shared with.
So basically, when you press this plus
button, it should add that user's
user data to the Shared With list for
the shopping list that you're sharing.
And again, that shopping list is
specified by the push ID here.
And when you press the button again, it
should remove that user from the shared
list, and
put the UI back to the gray plus button.
Alright, hopefully that's enough for
you to get started.
I'll send over the spec right away.